on on a trip on a journey like the
smallest interactions the smallest
things can just like be like a happy
story so I remember I remember on this
trip uh we're in like this town and like
the butt [ __ ] in the middle of nowhere
we we wanted lunch or whatever so we're
like oh let's let's see what restaurants
are about and uh there was this local
sushi restaurant
and we were all like cool I'm I'm
feeling Sushi let's do it and it's kind
of like it's kind of the sushi
restaurant that you there's like a
single counter and the menu they they
ain't no paper menu it's on the [ __ ]
wood blocks yeah on the wall you know
this is like old school this is like old
school hard level mode you know very
there ain't no tourists that can come
here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
I'm just like every time I've been to a
sushi restaurant like this I've had
someone Jeff I've had someone Japanese
to like helped me get through yeah we me
and Cindy will feel like we were like
feeling adventurous we're like you know
we've been in Japan for three years I
feel like we can do it yeah let's let's
just let's just go in sure and so and so
we go in and we we have that [ __ ]
Salon experience everyone shuts the [ __ ]
up they look at us
[Music]
you can see you can see the bomb and
sweating and I was like two people
please and they were like is the bar
okay and um everyone's silent like
everyone's silent we sit down and
complete silence the customers stop
talking and then and then the sushi chef
asks the magical words
and
we go where the quest begins
and everyone's like oh thank God that's
normally how it goes it does so it's not
me how it goes but that is literally the
equivalent of like in the cowboy times
of the bartender going are you looking
for trouble
the cowboy going not today thank God all
right we're good boys yeah and so as
soon as like that barrier was like
removed you know as soon as he knew that
one we could order and two he can have a
like a basic conversation with us like
every kind of like every kind of barrier
just shattered and they became like so
friendly and welcoming and like the
people next to us were also like very
talkative and everything like that as
well so they like asked us so are you
here visiting or you know are you living
here and uh we explained that you know
we're living here we're like YouTubers
working here and stuff like that
and then they went YouTube and then they
went everywhere YouTuber yes every time
every [ __ ] time and then Sydney and
then we get the like the usual questions
are like where we're from so I say I'm
like from England and Sydney's from
America
I don't know why but it was this is like
one of the cutest [ __ ] things I've
seen right so as soon as as soon as
Sydney says she's from America the sushi
chef like lights up and goes oh my God
my I have a grandson in America right
now right and he starts like he starts
going off about his grandson oh and like
we we eat our meal and he's just like
you know what I'm gonna call my grandson
right now and I don't know if he's I
don't know if he's awake right now but
I'm gonna try calling him so he gets on
this phone he gets out his phone and
this is why we're asking for well this
is why we're getting the bid and stuff
like that so he goes on his phone he
like calls his grandson and I think it's
like 1am in America when he's calling
him
just and his grandson picks up he starts
he starts speaking to his grandson and
he then he gives the phone to us
and then on the phone his grandson's
like I don't know what to really say to
you guys
in English yeah in English in English
Living in America and I was just like
yeah I don't really notes either you're
um you're we're just having your at your
grandpa's restaurant it's really really
nice and then we just have a random
conversation he's studying civil
engineering nice talking hero Good Luck
Good Luck hero you know and and just we
give the phone back and I was just like
I don't know what the grandpa was
expecting but he was so excited that I
just didn't want to let him down all you
Americans know each other
oh you're American my grandson's in
America you're you're you're you guys
are friends
oh my God and so we I'm so cute it's
it's so cute and then so we walk out we
walk out and we start exploring the town
a little more and there we fight we go
we go we find this festival or something
less going on and it's one of the most
random things things I'm seeing go into
this little town in Japan and then
there's this festival and there's a band
playing some music and the bands were
dressed up as Santa Claus Mario and the
exact same clown outfit I had for the
trash taste after dark special like they
had the exact same clown outfit yeah
so me and Cindy just sit down and we're
just like oh let's let's see what see
what let's let's see what this is about
so we sit down out of nowhere we get
[ __ ] recognized by a random person
there all right so I'm like and and I'm
like holy [ __ ] even here like we are
getting recognized I didn't I didn't
think there would be anyone here that
could you know that that would know
trash taste yeah no like us and
everything like that right so we're like
we're just so after after that incident
we were just like a little on guard not
on guard but just like oh that oh that
is aware that is a possibility so we're
just sitting down and then suddenly this
random Japanese blog just sits next sits
next to us like we're at a table he just
sits down and we're just like I need him
the first thing I the first thing I
thought was I must be a fan and I look
at him it's an old Japanese guy I'm like
this doesn't look like the usual trash
taste viewer
this that doesn't look like a dress and
I'm like what do you say in uh what do
you say in Japanese to be like what
what's going on yeah I'm sorry the
closest thing it goes is like
konnichiwait
which could be the most like passive
aggressive way of just being like um
excuse me because like in English I'd be
like hello mate are you okay and see if
you just and it's like the closest thing
we could think of is Konnichiwa
konichiwa yeah what are you doing there
and then so he takes his hat off it's
it's the sushi chef we didn't recognize
we didn't [ __ ] recognize him he just
[ __ ] sat down oh my gosh it's the
[ __ ] sushi chef holy [ __ ] like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] did he follow you huh no
yes
he says some we have uh we have a nice
to talk to my grandson again yeah we
have a nice little chat Hero's been
acting out yeah yeah we have a nice
little chat and everything and then like
he ends the conversation going like he
looks around and he goes see everyone
here
I know everyone here
it's like Anna's like oh okay boss man's
right here okay this is this is this is
the boss man
yeah yeah and then and then he goes if
you ever come back here please come back
to my sushi place he goes to me he goes
hey let's be friends I'm like oh my God
it's so cute oh my God what the [ __ ]
this is like this is like we need a
slice of Life anime revolve around this
guy and I'm like I feel like I that was
the exact moment where I'm just like
I get slices
I was just like I was just like I don't
know that little interaction just
brought me so much joy right now I was
just I agree with this when it's your
life that's a slice of your own life I
don't want to vicariously look through
it I don't want to [ __ ] watch someone
else succeed in life yeah have a good
time well I'm praying for a good time I
want to go out and have it
I was just like you know it's it's just
like little moments like that when I'm
just like yeah
his life is full I don't know I don't
know no that's awesome
I didn't I wasn't expecting that
interaction to be the moment where you
go home and you watch a slice life and
you're like that's like me for real it's
it's
a bit different sort of the anime with
the foreign
it's like you know you know when you the
little moments you see in Slice of Life
where it's just people going on
adventures
I had like the inverse where the the
news
sort out some [ __ ] other payment for
my other SIM cards and these foreigners
walked in and started and they were like
80 years old yeah foreigners I'm [ __ ]
foreigners walked in uh they were
clearly tourists and like they're like
yeah like 80 70 very very elderly yeah
uh and they started talking to the
people and they cleared it into getting
Japanese I just grabbed them like hey
what do you want by the way like what
are you what are you what's wrong yeah
uh because the Japanese people
yeah uh and they were like oh uh our SIM
cards don't work and on the top right
corner it says docomo so I think that
they can help me right and I'm like they
can't help you okay
I'm like they're not gonna help you I'm
Gonna Save You 30 minutes I'm gonna say
30 minutes just leave yes
it turned out they bought their SIM
cards online and and they they can call
each other yeah you can't it's the way
that they don't give out phone numbers
that's the point where it's like how
many layers do I need to go down to
explain yeah this [ __ ] ain't worse
hey you because they were they wanted to
call each other and I was like yeah you
can't do that no you can't get a phone
number in Japan unless you live here and
you you get a SIM card so I basically
just feel like yeah I'll be honest you
can have the data that works nice but
you won't be able to call each other
save yourself 40 minutes grab a WhatsApp
use that yeah I was like this they're
not gonna be able to help you I'm like
babe they don't do these Sims you they
had data only Sim and they thought they
had calls because they're advertising on
the plan they bought said calls but it
was kind of like a Skype thing and I was
just like don't bother literally the
dichotomy of the two different
experiences
you're not welcome here you have a great
Slice of Life experience or you can you
know you could walk into a document 30
minutes I told them I was like hey I'm a
customer I paid them monthly and I've
been here for an hour waiting for to get
something to happen yeah so I don't know
man maybe you should just enjoy your day
maybe you should just have a good time
yeah they're like maybe you want to call
each other I'm like you'll be fine no
you'll be right just just move together
as a group